[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actu à l'assemblée et
au sénat y pour commenter toute la
semaine passée notre invité est
aujourd'hui elle daffos tillon pour jour
vous êtes député communiste des
hauts-de-seine merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation avec plaisir
alors l info si on vous est né à amiens
comme emmanuel macron vous êtes entré en
politique en 2014 élue conseillère
municipale de gennevilliers en 2017 vous
êtes élue députée nouveau visage du
parti communiste dans lequel vous êtes
engagé depuis votre plus jeune âge vous
n'êtes pas ailleurs conseillère
départementale des hauts-de-seine et à
l'assemblée comme au conseil
départemental vous siéger dans
l'opposition
vous rêvez d'une riposte au parti
majoritaire d'un big bang de la gauche
et avec votre collègue insoumise
clémentine autain vous aviez d'ailleurs
proposé une alliance avec la france
insoumise est-ce toujours d'actualité ou
pas ah on propose plus que ça quand on
parle de big bang c'est pas juste une
alliance sera beaucoup plus loin est ce
que nous croyons c'est que à la fois il
ya une situation et on va y revenir
explosive dans le pays avec de la colère
sociale extrêmement légitime qui a
depuis un certain nombre d'années dé
colère qui s'exprime extrêmement
diverses mais à côté de ça il ya aussi
une gauche émiettée extrêmement affaibli
et en panne de projet et donc il ya
besoin de refonder cette gauche et ça
passera pas que par des alliances il ya
besoin évidemment de rassemblement mais
ça ne suffit pas et donc ce big bang il
appelle à la fois à des nouvelles formes
de rassemblement certainement plus
impliquante pour les citoyens mais aussi
du rassemblement politique syndical
associatif et puis de pouvoir construire
un projet politique autour à la fois de
la justice sociale et la justice
environnementale
donc c'est extrêmement d'actualité pour
nous que cette fondation
alors on va revoir la semaine
parlementaire avec vous le cap du
million de soutien qui a été franchie
pour le référendum pour la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris
elle les fonctionnaires dans le viseur
du sénat lors de l'examen
budget 2020 et enfin le vote à
l'assemblée d'une résolution
controversée sur la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
voilà donc pour l'ordre du jour mais
d'abord l'image de la semaine c'est
celle de la grève un du 5 décembre jeudi
noir dans les transports et journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites
huit cent mille personnes dans les rues
selon le ministère de l'intérieur
à l'appel des syndicats les cheminots
enseignants mais aussi les policiers ou
encore les avocats ont donc défilé jeudi
justement est la potion vous étiez dans
la rue jeudi
que pensez vous de ce mouvement où on a
vu quand même les syndicats ray bien
revigorés on a surtout vu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde
un déferlement un peu partout en france
moi j'étais évidemment à paris hier
hier après midi jeudi et ça fait du bien
de voir un cortège aussi déterminé aussi
joyeux et avec l'idée à la fois de faire
plier le gouvernement sur cette contre
réforme des retraites mais aussi je
crois avec une détermination à ouvrir
d'autres perspectives c'est parce que la
réforme des retraites pourrait passer de
mobilisation est ce que c'est de leur
vie dont parlent les gens qui
manifestaient l'expression des collabos
vous parliez il ya un instant c'est
l'expression à la fenêtre est
aujourd'hui évidemment d'un rejet de
cette contre-réforme des retraites qui
s'annonce
mais elle se place dans un contexte où
il y à des salariés qui ne vivent pas de
leur travail des hospitaliers qui voient
leur travail totalement déshumanisé des
enseignants pas assez payés et dont les
conditions d'enseignement
ils les jugent ils ont raison pas à la
hauteur des défis pour les enfants vous
les jeunes envers jean sélectionnant
justement de laquelle tu sais jamais
d'être incantatoires sur ce genre de
choses ça ne sert à rien de l'être ce
que l'on voit en revanche est dans ces
cortèges qu'on a vu c'est effectivement
et bien des personnes venant de secteurs
extrêmement différents mais qui
ressentent la même chose
il éprouve de la colère à voir leur vie
leurs droits en permanence rognés et en
même temps une aspiration extrêmement
forte
à
que eh bien cette vie puisse changer ils
savent que à la fois il ya des
injustices et des inégalités extrêmement
forte
ils savent qu'il ya des défis
environnementaux qui peuvent aussi
mettre des barrières extrêmement rapide
à la suite de leur vie et ils ne veulent
pas accepter que leurs enfants vont
vivre moins bien que est-ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement qui a dit que
la porte restait ouverte la porte des
négociations va entendre la colère de la
rue est peu modifié le texte le projet
de loi sur les retraites qui n'est pas
encore déposé ce que vous pensez que
vous avez entendu les le texte je vais
leur mais je vais le redire
il ya une volonté que cette réforme
tombe et c'est pour ça que les gens
étaient mobilisés mais pas que des
garanties vais demander la fin de la
région
la réforme elle repose sur le fait que
des gens vont y perdre qui vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps et qu'ils
doivent accepter que il va falloir se
partager la même assiette le même gâteau
avec plus de monde c'est ça le but de la
réforme faire travailler plus longtemps
est équilibré ou en tout cas à rogner
leur environnement évidemment que c'est
pas ça il dit que ce serait une réforme
plus juste en tout cas c'est le bruit
alors comme d'équité une réforme de
l'université qui vais-je les je peux
vous égrainé les moments où il a dit ça
le gouvernement il a dit que la loisy
l'immigration était une réforme un
projet de loi humaniste il a dit que la
loi blanc coeur était une loi de justice
sociale vous avez repart en tout cas je
peux constater que les effets en tout
cas annoncé sur ces réformes n'étaient
évidemment pas celle qui était dit par
le gouvernement et que les citoyens
c'est pas simplement les députés où les
parlementaires en général les citoyens
ils le vivent ça donc ils voient bien
que les mots annoncé et les effets
produits ont pas simplement une
différence mais un écart b en hesse que
sur le fond tout de même vous jugé qu'
on peut faire une bonne réforme des
retraites à ce qu'il en faut une une
réforme systémique par arriver un
système plus universel et qui refonte
même les quarante deux régimes de
retraite alors universelle ça peut
vouloir dire plein de choses à partir du
moment où il annonce universel heckly 17
pas prendre en compte
et bien qu un ouvrier a une espérance de
vie bien un haut cadre c'est une
coquille vide
diddy on peut dire aussi que les
réformes successives depuis 93 ont
affaibli les droits des travailleurs et
donc des futurs retraités et qu'il
faudrait revenir dessus par exemple
parce que nous sommes et nous étions
plus fortement encore un pays où est
bien les retraités n'étaient pas aussi
pauvres que dans d'autres pays et que
les réformes successives et celle qui se
prépare est dans la même logique on
affaiblit en tout cas les revenus des
retraités donc c'est non alors en
attendant la suite de la mobilisation et
le projet de loi qui doit venir à
l'assemblée parlons d'une autre image
qui a fait l'actualité cette semaine ses
parlementaires d'opposition unis pour
une même cause
[Musique]
ils sont députés et sénateurs de droite
de gauche ils veulent obtenir un
référendum sur la privatisation décidées
par le gouvernement d'adb ils ont obtenu
plus d'un million de signatures pour
leurs projets un cap de franchi mais la
route du référendum est encore longue
fanny d'ail et thomas des prêts mercredi
matin devant le palais bourbon
des dizaines de députés et sénateurs de
l'opposition célèbre le million de
signatures recueillies pour réclamer un
référendum sur la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris
mais le rip le référendum d'initiative
partagée c'est un peu comme une course
d'obstacles qui dure déjà depuis six
mois ont franchi une étape on attend un
million de signatures
j'aime mieux vous dire qu'on les a pas
trouvés sous le pas d'un cheval
il a fallu aller les chercher un million
c'est une performance extraordinaire
compte tenu de toutes les difficultés
qui ont été mises en travers de façon
vraiment délibéré l'objectif obtenir 4
millions 700 mille signatures comme le
prévoit la constitution depuis 2008 un
seuil difficile à atteindre
à tel point qu'en avril dernier emmanuel
macron lui même a évoqué la possibilité
d'abaisser le nombre de soutiens
nécessaires pour déclencher un rip
est ce que je souhaite c'est que dans le
cadre de notre réforme constitutionnelle
nous puissions aller plus loin sur le
référendum d'initiative partagée en en
simplifiant les règles en permettant que
l'initiative puissent venir de citoyens
un million de citoyens qui signerait une
pétition et qu'elle puisse prospérer en
projet de loi et si elle n'était pas
examiné par les assemblées aller au
référendum
nous y sommes faut que je dise oui au
président de la république nous vous
avons écouté nous avons entendu entendez
le million qui souhaite qu'il y ait un
référendum sur 7 sur cette question
importante
sauf que la réforme envisagée par le
président n'a pas encore eu lieu
pour la majorité donc les opposants à la
privatisation d'atp sont encore loin du
compte
en l'état la loi parce qu'elle a été
votée si les 4,7 millions de signataires
ne sont pas atteints alors la
privatisation sera mien
la collecte des signatures s'achèvera au
mois de mars il reste trois mois aux
partisans du riz pour se mobiliser alors
une première question emmanuel macron
peut-il ignorer un million de signatures
alors qu'il a lui-même envisagé l'idée
qu'on puisse déclencher un rythme
infernal positive à partir de 10
millions déjà c'est étonnant ce qui est
dit dans le reportage
parce que emmanuel macron peut décider
d'un référendum quand ils le souhaitent
il en a la possibilité en tant que
président de la république est
d'ailleurs lui seul peut le faire
aujourd'hui
en dehors des 4 millions 7 une période
dure ips et sa prérogative donc lui qui
a annoncé que dans le cadre de la
réforme constitutionnelle qui semble un
peu s'échapper au fur et à mesure du
temps et bien si elle n'est pas là sur
la table dans l'année à venir dans les
quelques mois à venir lui peut prendre
l'initiative d'avoir un référendum
vu qu'il a dit que un million lui
semblait et bien à une étape important
que l'egypte chez nous le considérons
chiche
évidemment il doit maintenant le faire
et il s'est engagé quelque part lors du
grand débat national là dessus pourquoi
il s'est engagé parce qu'il avait bien
compris dans le cadre des mobilisations
des gilet jaune que cette aspiration à
de la démocratie et essai présent dans
de très nombreux mouvements sociaux
aujourd'hui on peut balayer les
mouvements sociaux qui dans le monde
aujourd'hui au coeur à chaque fois de
ces mobilisations il ya les questions
démocratiques les questions des
institutions donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose d' extrêmement profond dans la
société chez les citoyens qui le
revendique et donc un million c'est
effectivement pas rien c'est une étape
importante
donc aujourd'hui nous demandons à
emmanuel macron de respecter les
engagements pris lors de ce grand débat
et de convoquer un référendum
est-ce que vous pensez que sur le fond
le gouvernement va tenir sur la
privatisation de la dp lorsque l'on voit
quand même qu'il ya ce million de
signatures au delà même de la question
du référendum à ce que ce n'est pas déjà
perdu du côté de l'opinion publique
c'est ce qui va se passer ça c'est
toujours enfin
des anticipations avec des revirements
parfois qu'on n'attend pas qu'on a pas
prêt en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que l'exécutif emmanuel macron devrait
entendre ses multiples contestations à
la fois par bout c'est-à-dire retraite
hôpital école privatisation mais qui
forment une contestation globale d'un
projet de société donc au jeu sur adp
oui oui j'entends mais c'est quand même
assez j'ai pas que je vais utiliser
historique inédit en tout cas le fait
que ça soit par tous et pan aujourd'hui
que ça craque que ça conteste et que ça
aspire à autre j'ai un exemple de plus
fine c'est un mais c'est un exemple
important parce que la privatisation
d'un secteur comme celui là est
évidemment quelque chose qui à mon avis
tu dis quelque chose aujourd'hui de ce
que ne veulent plus les citoyens de ce
pays
donc nous en tout cas on l'appelle
évidemment et bien à se faire une
opinion
il peut laisser le choix aux citoyens
aujourd'hui de décider qu'il le fasse
sur le fond on sera pas l'un des
arguments du gouvernement et la ville
fait valoir qu'il s'agissait seulement
d'une concession de 70 ans qui permet
aussi d'alimenter un fonds pour
l'innovation que ce n'est pas à l'état
de gérer des duty free que vous qu'est
ce que vous répondez vous à ce type
d'arguments ou à écouter vraiment ce
moment déjà sur l'argument des duty free
écoutez le le pdg d'aéroports de paris
augustin de romanet vous pensez vraiment
que cet homme de confiance des
gouvernements successifs qui a été placé
là de manière extrêmement choisis
précise serait un pdg de duty free c'est
vraiment une vaste blague que de dire ça
donc on est bien sûr un secteur
stratégique avec les aéroports de paris
stratégique d'ailleurs aussi à l'avenir
est maintenant sur la question
environnementale parce qu'il faut
pouvoir continuer à faire du choix et
sur la question financière je crois que
les parlementaires d'opposition de
manière très large ont pu y compris la
droite y compris la droite car elle joue
aux côtés selon lui tout à fait mais
écoutez images atone ans que la droite
tire le son de la privatisation des
autoroutes par exemple
et du fait qu' on était vraiment sur un
fiasco
une gabegie financière et qui puisse
dire aujourd'hui ça suffit nous avons
fait erreur nous pouvons reconnaître que
nous avons fait l'erreur ne le fait pas
sur les aéroports
et bien tant mieux allez on va passer au
temps fort de la semaine au sénat qui
poursuit l'examen du budget 2009 1
[Musique]
lundi soir le sénat avait les
fonctionnaires dans le viseur entre
allongement du temps de travail et
instauration de trois jours de carence
en cas de maladie retour sur ces mesures
symboliques adopté grâce aux voix de la
droite sénatoriale
sandra cerqueira des amendements qui
visent la fonction publique
il en est question chaque année lors de
l'examen du budget au sénat pour celui
de 2020 la majorité de droite veut
imposer trois jours de carence aux
fonctionnaires pour arrêt maladie
augmenter le délai de carence pour
lutter contre l'absentéisme
l'argument n'est pas nouveau albéric de
montgolfier l'avait déjà défendu lors de
l'examen du budget il y a deux ans à la
fois par des raisons d'équité avec les
secteurs privé et bien sûr pour des
raisons d'économie je vous rappelle que
code le jour de carence avaient été
supprimés il avait une forte
augmentation de l'absentéisme la
fonction publique et nous souhaitons
lutter contre cet homme sauter ici
le sénat a aussi voté pour un
allongement du temps de travail
hebdomadaire dans la fonction publique
et diminuer de moitié les augmentations
de salaires liée à l'ancienneté à gauche
ces amendements ne passe pas et son vécu
comme un acharnement anti fonctionnaires
les agents les fonctionnaires je pète il
se met en maladie après avoir consulté
un médecin et c'est un médecin qui
jugent de leur état de santé monsieur le
rapporteur général c'est pas le
politique c'est pas le législateur qui
s'occupe de ça il ya un clivage entre la
majorité sénatoriale et d'autres
composantes ici notre sénat c'est haro
sur dépense publique dépense publique
dépense publique dépense publique on
entend que ça depuis le début sur la loi
de finances
la droite a voulu marquer le coup son
objectif c'est bien de montrer que selon
elle le gouvernement n'en fait pas assez
pour réduire les dépenses en ne
supprimant par exemple que 47 emplois
dans la fonction publique en 2020 donc
c'est pas raisonnable
donc quand on veut faire des économies
qu'on veut s'attaquer à dépenses
publiques faut bien à un moment m du
symbole et on a donné dans le symbole et
quand tu fais rien que les choses relève
du réglementaire etc rien n'est fait en
réglementaire que tout doit être fait
dans la dans la négociation et que rien
n'est fait dans les négociations alors
on est un peu obligé d'être un peu à la
serre les amendements ont tous été voté
contre l'avis du gouvernement qui
reviendra dessus à l'assemblée ces
mesures n'entreront donc pas en vigueur
elle a fait si on voit là un sujet on le
retrouve et bien le clivage droite
gauche pour le coup trois jours de
carence dans le public comme dans le
privé
la droite estime que c'est une mesure
d'équité et d'économie l équité
visiblement c'est toujours vers le bas
donc c'est moins de droits pour tout le
monde
rappelons quand même que dans le privé
heureusement il ya aussi des salariés
couverts par des conventions collectives
pas forcément par la loi mais par des
conventions collectives et que donc
leurs jours de carence sont eux aussi
pris en charge par ces conventions
collectives et jeudi heureusement parce
que mon collègue savoldelli le rappeler
mais oui quand on est malade on va voir
un médecin qui effectivement peut
considérer que il ya un moment où il
faut pas aller travailler parce que ça
va permettre tout simplement de se
remettre plus vite aussi au travail que
de se reposer
c'est à la fois pour le bien du salarié
mais aussi pour le bien est bien de sa
force de travail il l'art constitue pour
pouvoir aller travailler
donc là vous dites qu'on est sur un
symbole on est surtout sur le coeur
d'une politique de droite qui cible les
fonctionnaires pas simplement la dépense
publique je veux dire pourquoi ne pas se
mettre en situation de lutter
efficacement ils ont été en
responsabilité contre l'évasion fiscale
pour amener des recettes supplémentaires
sur la suppression de liesse f1 il ya
des moyens en herbe sont pas de dégager
mais évidemment que non et puis
regardons il ya le gel du point d'indicé
là on va toucher enfin je l'espère
j'espère bien que non mais en tout cas
il ya un gouvernement qui entend
s'attaquer à leur retraite ya des
hospitaliers au bord du gouffre en tout
cas il a de la versio nerfs dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
oui dont il a défendu la qu'on attende à
lui contre un amendement de la droite au
sénat
il pourrait peut-être s'occuper de leurs
points d'un 10 de leur retraite du
salaire des enseignants voilà qui
permettrait de montrer un gouvernement
qui s'occupe des fonctionnaires est ce
que c'est un comble justement que le
gouvernement soit apparue comme le grand
défenseur de fonctionnaires dans
l'hémicycle face à la droite sénatoriale
je vous avoue que je vous laisse ces
termes de grands défenseurs il faut pas
exagérer voilà ils ont refusé un
amendement qu'ils n'avaient pas choisi
il ya d'autres on peut regarder les
différents pans du budget et montrer que
effectivement on parle pas de grands
défenseurs des fonctionnaires de la part
du gouvernement
on a vu des suppressions de postes je
répète le gel du point d'indicé
beaucoup de mesures qui fragilise le
statut des fonctionnaires et puis il ya
eu la réforme de la fonction publique
aussi bien la nouvelle vous étiez
activement tout à fait qu'un gars gdf
est d'ailleurs le gouvernement est allé
un petit peu dans ce sens là puisqu'il
ya eu l'instauration d'un jour de
carence pour les fonctionnaires en 2017
quel bilan peut-on en tirer pour vous
écouter faudrait je vous avoue que
faudrait que je regarde un peu plus
précisément de mémoire et en toute
honnêteté on en parlait pendant pendant
le sujet peu peu de peu d'effet ou en
tout cas sur sur l'aspect financier sur
l'aspect économique
en revanche qu'on peut se dire c'est
qu'effectivement et bien tout simplement
je le répète on est malade on a le droit
à un moment de pouvoir prendre
scinderont g maladie c'est un droit moi
je je je veux bien qu'à chaque fois
qu'on accorde un droit à quelqu'un on
puisse regarder l'impact c'est normal
c'est notre rôle de parlementaire mais
soyons fier à un moment quand on
attribue des droits aux gens c'est aussi
notre mission que de pouvoir regarder je
le disais il ya pas longtemps mais au
20e siècle
il ya des gens qui se sont battus de
manière importante ont mené des
conquêtes sociales et à chaque fois il
se disait ça va pas être possible
j'ai pas si vous souvenez du film la
gloire de mon père quand il ya cet
enseignant le père de marcel qui devant
ses profs dit on va être le siècle de la
semaine de 40 heures et il ya ces élèves
qui ont les yeux totalement écarquillés
et il n'y croit pas sauf qu'à chaque
fois eh bien ça c'était des conquêtes
qui arrivait et on arrivait vers du
mieux en se disant nos enfants vont
enfin vivre mieux que nous et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve au 21e siècle
avec des possibles incroyable des
richesses incroyables et on devrait
expliquer à nos enfants qui vont vivre
moins bien mais voilà c'est on marche
évidemment sur sur la tête et donc il ya
besoin est bien de pouvoir envisager de
nouveaux droits pour les citoyens de ce
pays et c'est possible en tout cas ces
mesures de la droite c'est nathan
ne ne passeront pas le cap de
l'assemblée le texte le projet doit
revenir gouvernement rétablira la
version initiale dernière question à
l'ordre du jour elle à fouzilhon comment
mieux définir et combattre
l'antisémitisme
[Musique]
la proposition de résolution était
discutée mardi en séance publique le
débat dans l'hémicycle a été vive
certains craignaient que le vote de ce
texte vous sans valeur contraignante
empêche toute critique de la politique
d'israël écouter sylvain maillard
auteurs de cette proposition de
résolution
il nous faut apporter une réponse à
cette question essentielle qu'est ce que
l'antisémitisme du 21e siècle c'est
justement le sens de cette proposition
de résolution visant à adopter la
définition de l'antisémitisme de
l'alliance internationale pour la
mémoire de l'holocauste
cette définition la voici
l'antisémitisme est une certaine
perception des juifs qui peut se
manifester par une haine à leur égard
les manifestations rhétorique et
physique de l'antisémitisme ville des
individus juifs ou non et où leurs biens
des institutions communautaires et des
lieux de culte
il s'agit avec cette définition de
raffermir les pratiques de nos forces de
l'ordre de nos magistrats de nos
enseignants et le de leur permet de
mieux appréhender l'antisémitisme qui
prend parfois aussi les traits de
l'antisionisme alors la discussion dans
l'hémicycle a été vive le texte a été
adopté avec 150 voix pour et 72 voix
contre l info sion qu'avez vous votez et
pourquoi expliquez nous j'ai voté contre
cette résolution rappelons que au départ
il y avait l'ambition d'une proposition
de loi la part de sylvain maillard qui
du coup a reculé parce que il ressentait
je crois assez et plus qu'en tenant une
pièce ne les aime plus contraignantes
et donc il a reculé ans en tant qu
évidemment pouvait y avoir une majorité
contre sa proposition de loi la
résolution est moins contraignante mais
tout de même allés voter elle dit
quelque chose politiquement de la part
de l'assemblée
moi je regrette parce que je crois à une
opération politicienne de la part de la
majorité et de sylvain maillard avec
avec cette proposition
elle n'aura pas d'effectivité au sens
effectifs pénal etc
puisqu'on sait que eh bien j'ai une
femme sur sur l'aspect pénal les choses
existent déjà pour condamner toutes les
formes de racisme et l'antisémitisme
pourquoi là je dois dire d'abord tout de
suite que évidemment nous sommes chacun
chacune et ça s'est traduit lors des
débats inquiet de la montée ou même des
actes antisémites antisémite extrêmement
violents ont la visite à voir cette
semaine
raisonner avec bien sûr la profanation
avec la nation dire de westhoffen en a
évidemment ma la première profanation
n'en tombe depuis plusieurs me souviens
petite fille de carpentras qui avait
évidemment beaucoup marqué cette mémoire
là est donc évidemment il ya cette
inquiétude là ce que je pense c'est que
m tenter de mettre un trait d'égalité
aujourd'hui entre l'antisionisme et
l'antisémitisme nous des vies d'un
combat résolu contre c'est ça qui nous a
conduit à vous évidemment l'essayer en
fait et d'ailleurs on l'a ressenti dans
les expressions cet après midi là à
tenter quelque part de se payer celles
et ceux qui critiquent la politique
d'israël de manière légitime car s'ils
vont pas identiques colonisatrice une
politique qui bafoue les droits
internationaux sur des textes votés par
la france auprès de l'onu
sylvain malade même jeu je la dis mais
on doit pouvoir critiquer israël sa
politique mais on ne doit pas lui nier
son droit d'exister dans ce cas là pour
lui on est antisémite il dit qu on a
quand même le droit à cette
à cette critique mais pas le droit de
nier son existence ou de lui contester
son existence non mais on n'est pas déjà
évidemment que l'antisionisme ne peut
pas être le même
au 20ème siècle qu'il est au 21e il
pouvait y avoir des gens qui pensaient
qu'il ne devait pas y avoir des tas
comme israël au 20e siècle
au 21ème siècle cet état existe
aujourd'hui je suis une militante pour
les droits et je réclame deux états donc
je ne conteste pas le fait
qu'aujourd'hui il existe par contre
aujourd'hui les fondée par sa politique
sur une politique colonisatrice qui
bafoue les droits internationaux
voilà pour moi ce que c'est la critique
de la politique d'israël est ce qu'elle
est antisioniste avec les mêmes termes
que ceux du 20e siècle
non mais elle peut s'apparenter dans les
propos de sylvain maillard en tout cas
ce que je pense aujourd'hui de l'état
d'israël à de l'antisionisme donc vous
voyez bien que cette nuance est
extrêmement fine et je veux dire juste
une chose s'il y a des personnes
aujourd'hui qui se cache derrière de
l'antisionisme pour être antisémite
eh bien on les repère facilement ils
sont antisémites points et ils auront
des propos et des actes antisémites
et pour ça il existe aujourd'hui la loi
est tout simplement la loi il faut
qu'elle puisse s'appliquer et il faut de
l'éducation de l'éducation populaire
notamment et nous avons besoin de clé à
mon avis pour le faire pas de résolution
qui sème la confusion
merci à la faucille on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo bonne suite de
programmes sur chaîne parlementaire une
très bonne journée à tous à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]